so we're talking about navigation how
you know where you are and how you can
get from here to wherever else you want
to go
and last time we talked about just the
general problems that arise in
navigation and we talked about the para
hippocampal place area
and other
parts of the brain that are involved in
navigation so today we're going to
continue that but we're going to talk
more about the actual populations of
neurons in your head that are involved
in doing this and we'll talk about a
particular aspect of the problem of
navigation which is called reorientation
that's what happens when you lose your
bearings and you need to figure out
where you are again reset your
internal
map of yours of where you are
and then we'll talk about the idea that
this whole system for navigation cool as
it is and fascinating as navigation
itself is is even more interesting
because there's increasing evidence that
we use that same system for lots of
other aspects of high-level cognition
that have nothing to do with space per
se
okay that's the and then we'll have a
quiz short quiz
that's the agenda here we go so the
basic problems of navigation are one
where am i
and two how do i get from here to
wherever else i want to go
and as i mentioned last time we can
break down each of these into a bunch of
different components and facets of that
question so when we want to know where
we are
that can that can involve recognizing a
familiar location so if you see a
photograph or you were plunked down
spontaneously in an environment
someplace you know you would visually
recognize it and that would be one way
to know where you were like this is my
living room
even if that location is unfamiliar and
you're plunked down at random you still
have some idea of what kind of a place
this is am i in a natural environment an
urban environment am i inside am i
outside et cetera
and finally you had you would have some
sense of where you are with respect to
the immediate bounding
structures in your immediate environment
like for example where you are in this
room like as i'm talking to you right
now i'm aware that there's a wall behind
me right
that kind of immediate
spatial
location
in terms of questions that arise when we
have to figure out how do we get from
here to wherever else we want to go
if you can directly see or hear your
destination then you have the simplest
possible kind of navigation strategy you
just go toward that thing okay that's
called beaconing and it's like the
minimalist case works great if you can
see or hear your destination
but when you can't
you need to know
where am i in this in my broader
understanding of the layout of my
environment and where is my goal and for
that you need a mental map of your
environment and we'll talk more about
that today that's why it's in red
you also need to know your current
heading in that environment it's not
enough to know in my map of the world i
am here with a dot you need to know
which way you're facing in that map of
the world in order to plan your
navigation we'll talk about that too
we also need to know what routes are
possible from here so i may want to go
over to stata and get a cup of coffee
but i can't go this way i got to go
around because i can't go through that
glass okay and so finally that this
whole magnificent system that enables us
to process all this stuff works pretty
impressively but every once in a while
something will go wrong and it will you
know get the wrong signal and then we're
lost and so then we need a way to regain
our bearings and we'll talk about that
too
um so
last time i talked about a bunch of
brain regions that are implicated in
perceiving scenes and in navigation
we talked about the perihipic apple
place area right here and this region
over here formerly known as tos now
known as opa you don't need to remember
all that it's the bit that's out on the
lateral surface that we can zap because
it's out there
and both of those regions seem to be
involved broadly in perceiving the shape
of space around you
we also talked a bit about retrosplenial
cortex that region that's hiding in the
sulcus here that you can see better when
you mathematically unfold the sulcus
there it is responds more to scenes and
objects and that region seems to be
involved in something like getting your
bearings that is the location and
orientation of where you are
with respect to your cognitive map and
environment okay so to make that a
little more vivid i gave you one
description of a patient before but
here's from another study
patients with damage to retrosplenial
cortex
so here's from a recent article in every
case the patient with this damage was
able to recognize landmarks in their
neighborhoods and retained a sense of
familiarity i know that place that's the
coffee shop five blocks from my house
right but despite that
none of those patients were able to find
their way in familiar environments and
all but one were unable to learn new
routes so they can recognize visual the
visual form of a particular place but
they don't know how to relate that to
their cognitive map of the world and
their therefore plan a route from there
okay
okay
so um the part that i only alluded to at
the end yes question
okay is the
retros cortex home to the clock on the
cops or is it
great question we don't exactly know the
typical story is that the home of the
cognitive map is the hippocampus which
we're about to talk talk about next for
reasons i will tell you but all of this
is kind of this is a very active area of
research it kills me every time i do
these lectures i look at my old notes
and i think here are these 10 other
awesome studies and then i try to fit
them in and then they just don't fit so
actually one question i want to ask you
guys after this lecture is should i in
future either later in this course or in
future courses allocate even more time
or do you guys feel like okay enough
already with navigation but i just think
it's the coolest system so there's lots
of work
exactly trying to answer that kind of
question and i'll give you
a current snapshot of the approximate
state but all of this is in flux and
very much actively investigated
okay
so
cognitive map what do we mean by that
just to remind you of this classic study
from the 1940s in rats where the rat
when they learned this route and then
went up here and found their gold block
the rat immediately comes out and goes
straight toward the goal telling you
they've learned something much more
interesting than the series of left and
right turns to get to the goal they must
have done something much more like
actually learned the layout of space and
the relative position of that goal so
they could come up with a new vector to
get there when the original route was
blocked
okay
and you guys can do this too right when
your root is blocked you come up with a
novel root right
uh and you do that by having some
knowledge of your environment something
tantamount to that in your head
some version of that
and further you know where you are in
that map like right now you know where
you are
okay
now here's the cool thing
specific neurons in your hippocampus
right now are firing telling you that
you are right there
okay
so these neurons are called place cells
and this is what they do okay so i'll be
a place cell or what rather what i'll do
is i will act out the activity of a
place cell by a series of clicks i will
make as i walk around so imagine there's
an electrode in my hippocampus and you
are hearing the activity of a single
neuron in my hippocampus as i walk
around and here's what it would do
you'd hear background firing so it's
going to go click click
click click click noisy background
finding firing click click
click click
click click click click click
click click click click click click
click click click click click
click
click click okay i'm not going to go
down there click click click click click
click look click click click click click
click click click
click click click click
click click click
so that's one neuron that fires only
when i'm right over there that place
it's not where i'm facing over there
it's not what i'm looking at
particularly it's when i'm right there
okay that's a place cell
and so there's lots of place cells in
your hippocampus
that do that and they do it for
different locations in your environment
and all of this was first worked out of
course in rodents who were running
around who had electrodes in their
hippocampus but where those electrodes
were connected with a loose tether so
that the rodent could move around in
their environment while recording from
individual neurons in the campus okay so
that's the setup
and so i'm going to show you a movie of
an aerial view
of a rodent
moving around
a rat moving around in its environment
can you see the little rat there
um and what's happening is this um video
is tracing out the rat's path with the
light gray and every time that it's
recording from one neuron every time
that neuron fires it makes a red dot and
so this is obviously sped up but as the
rat moves around in his environment you
see an accumulation like more firing
when the rat is right there
it's not which direction the rat is
going through when he goes there just
basically whenever he passes through
that in any direction
neurons fire more than anywhere else and
then if we take that and blur it as
scientists like to do to make nice
idealized pictures
that is the place cell for that neuron
that is the place in space
that that animal has to be to make that
neuron fire
yeah question is it one dimension
i mean can multiple cases be mapped to
save your home um that's complicated
in an immediate environment like this
generally not okay i'll show you some
examples in a moment
it's more complicated if you follow that
cell when the animal moves to new
locations so let me say a few more
things and then i'll then if it's not
clear i'll take questions oops i'm going
to see it again
okay right so so in answer to josh's
question here are a bunch of place cells
from a rodent exploring the same
environment so you might say well
there's like a hot spot here and a
little sub one there but in general most
of these cells respond with a hot spot
in a particular single location in this
particular environment
okay did you have a different question
about that yes
so
that all depends on the wrath
um
the unconscious of the fact whether it's
in that place
if the rat was anesthetized or if he was
you know blindfolded and you passively
moved him around in that space and he
had no idea no way to tell where he was
that wouldn't work however if the rat
knows the environment
and then you do this in a darkened room
where he's actively locomoting around
these things will still work pretty well
because rats are very good at keeping
track of where they are
even without visual cues if they know
the environment they'll have other cues
like tactile cues and like they will
know how far they went in each direction
remember i talked briefly about the
tunisian ants doing dead reckoning
right keeping track of their vector and
speed at each moment and integrating the
whole thing to know where they are
that's called dead reckoning rats are
pretty good at that too
another question over here yeah
um the police officers do they have like
uh look at math as well like how like
we'll get there great question we'll get
there
i'll just give you the answer no they
don't it's too bad um
they could have they could have been all
organized but it's actually a little
complicated how would you organize them
then what if you like learned more stuff
off of the edge of space well like i had
a whole other piece of your hippocampus
i would be inconvenienced so maybe
that's why it doesn't work whereas with
visual space
you know you're your retina topic
information always stays the same we
don't have to suddenly add
a whole new part of retinotopic space
thereby screwing up our retina topic
maps in the brain i'm just making that
up as a possible reason i don't know if
that's why yeah what's sorry behind you
david who what's tell me your name
justin yeah right hi um so i was
wondering like if you're in a smaller
space comparatively or like a bigger
space right like
more areas of these specific uh place
cells that like what they're mapping to
um will they also scale up right now
it's a great question i don't know the
answer my guess is they'll scale
according to the space
right like so if if i had if that if my
place my fake place cell field that i
just acted out over there is maybe five
feet across if i was then confined to a
little space you'd probably have smaller
ones for that space but i don't know
let me say a little bit more about this
so so just to catch this out the place
field is the location in space the
animal has to be to make that
hippocampal cell fire okay
so
let's distinguish that from a receptive
field in visual cortex which is a
similar idea but a different one a
receptive field in visual cortex is the
location in the visual field where a
stimulus has to be to make a visual
neuron fire
not where the animal itself has to be
where the stimulus has to be okay so
keep those ideas separate they're
related but different
okay so what about you know we and
rodents tend to go around mostly on a 2d
plane
that is we have buildings and trees and
stuff we sometimes go up in the z-axis
but most we live in a 2d plane
but that's not true of all animals so
recall the bat that i mentioned last
time these amazing flyers and navigators
who fly in 3d and complicated
trajectories and yet have
amazing abilities to keep track of where
they are over 30 to 50 miles that they
fly at night
and even as they change their
orientation
well it turns out that in the
hippocampus of bats there's a bunch of
work where people have
put
um remote
what do you call these things recording
devices on bats where you can remotely
record
neural activity in the hippocampus as
the bat flies around
and turns out that bats have play cells
too and their place cells
as they they all also can do this in a
lab environment where they're flying
around and you keep track of their
location uh with cameras so you know
exactly where they are in 3d space
and it turns out that place cells in
bats are three-dimensional because bats
live in a three-dimensional world
so whereas rodent these would be a bunch
of kind of schematized place cells
for uh of different hippocampal cells in
a rodent
these are different place cells
for different hippocampal cells and a
bat
makes sense bats need this they need to
know not making sense okay so the bat is
moving around in three dimensions its
place field isn't just like the one i
did there i can't act this out because i
can't fly but that play cell might fire
over in that location but then if the
bat flew directly above it it wouldn't
so it's got three dimensions okay
um okay
so i said before that i had one of those
and i acted it out but what's the
evidence for that
that evidence in humans came way after
the evidence in rodents
um because as you can imagine it's
harder to arrange to record from
individual neurons in human
hippocampuses
nonetheless
as i've mentioned a few times there are
occasional opportunities where a
neurosurgeon has stuck an electrode in
an interesting part of the brain for
clinical reasons and the patient and the
neurosurgeon are nice enough
to let scientists collect data
so i'm going to show you a really gross
bloody picture if that's going to bother
you just look away okay
so um this is neurosurgery you take the
skull off you take the dura off that's
the direct surface of the brain the
neurosurgeons stick electrodes right on
top of there and in this case they put
them deep inside the brain okay the
gross pictures are gone we have just a
nice clean
uh x-ray here um so in these cases these
are um
this is a patient who's got an electrode
sticking straight into the brain from
the surface straight down into the
hippocampus
okay
kind of horrifying but
sometimes clinically called for seizures
very often start in hippocampus so this
is a common place for
clinicians to put electrodes
um and so uh what would you do if you
had a patient who was willing to do your
short experiment while hanging out in
the hospital waiting to have a seizure
with electrodes in their hippocampus
well duh you'd have them play a little
um a little game in a virtual space and
some kind of you don't even need vr you
can use a pretty
cheesy little video game and i'm sure
this one was quite cheesy this study was
done back in 2003
so
they had patients navigate through a
space this is an aerial view of the
space the patients didn't see that they
saw this kind of front view and they
kind of navigated around with the
joystick in that space and there were
three
kind of visually recognizable kind of
locations in that space and they had to
do things to go from one location to
another
okay details don't really matter
so all the while um ekstrom and
colleagues are recording from individual
neurons in this patient's hippocampus
okay
so here's an example of a place cell so
this is a diagram of the space i just
showed you right with those
three recognizable locations and other
locations that the patient could
virtually navigate through with the
joystick the red lines are the patient's
trajectory as they moved around in that
space
and the colors within each square are
the average firing rate
when the patient navigated through that
location
and so this is the place field of that
individual cell in this patient's brain
as they went through this space because
the firing rate there was around five
hertz compared to you know three hertz
for some other locations and mostly
lower than that
okay does that make sense so we're just
just like the rodent experiment but it's
a person with a joystick looking at this
space as they go through this virtual
environment and we're mapping out their
place fields like that okay
so that shows that humans have placed
fields in their hippocampus just as
rodents and bats do yeah
all this is like independent of
landmarks
um that's a very complicated question
this patient had access to landmarks
they are seeing as they go through
so one could ask for example if you did
it with your eyes closed and you had to
go by dead reckoning remembering the
left and right turns you had in a
familiar environment how well could
these things go they would go for at
least a while
they'd probably go for longer in rodents
because rodents
are more accustomed to navigating in the
dark and they rely less on visual cues
and more on other cues
but yeah these are not
place cells aren't just visually
responsive right so
if we had like for example if we set up
a a um a distinctive sound source in
this corner of the room and a different
you know like say somebody was singing
quietly over here
and we um
tied a dog over there who was barking
right and you you walked around in this
room with your eyes closed you'd have a
pretty you'd have a good way to keep
track of your bearings as you moved
around because you'd know that the
singing was coming from here and the dog
barking was coming from there you
wouldn't be seeing anything your eyes
would be closed but your place cells
would work pretty well okay so whenever
you have some basis for knowing where
you are no matter what modality is
telling you that
usually it's many modalities those place
cells will go
okay
okay so humans have these things too so
you can think of the place cell as the
kind of you are here system right
that is the whole set of place cells any
one place will only tell you are you in
this particular location or not but you
have a whole array of them then
collectively
that that whole representation across
all of those neurons can tell you where
you are in your familiar environment
okay
but if you want to not just know where
you are but you want to go somewhere
else like there
you also need to know your current
heading as we discussed last time okay
so it turns out
that there's a whole other batch of
cells
that tell you what way you're heading
okay these are called head direction
cells
also first studied in rodents
and each head direction cell responds
when that rodent is heading in a
particular direction
not in another direction
okay so for example
you have you know
if we're mapping along the x-axis
different heading direction so the
rodent is facing in different directions
in his environment you map up the whole
360 degrees
this would be the response of one cell
as that
rodent moves around
this one will be tuned to this
particular direction it would fire only
when the rodent was facing this way not
when it was facing this way or this way
or this way or this way
okay
so everybody get how where you are in
space is different that's not a very
good way to show this
where you are in space
is different from where you're
aimed and headed in that location okay
two orthogonal axes of
relevant to your location yeah
so this isn't the angle of the head
respect the body right it's the entire
um i think
i meant to look that up again because
this question always arises um i think
that there's some muck about that in the
literature which is why i never remember
a clear answer usually in a rodent
especially they're the same
um
and whether you know because you know
runs can turn their heads a little bit
but you know mostly they're gonna
keep it aimed the way they're moving
um so i don't know this is a long
complicated excuse that i forget what
the answer to that is um but send me an
email and i'll look it up i meant to
before this lecture just ran out of time
um
okay
most of the time they'll be the same i
actually i'm i'm pretty sure it's which
way your body's facing because if i turn
like this well anyway i'm not going that
way yeah and have you found at least 360
cents for each sort of angle
i mean are there cells for each yes yes
they they pretty much evenly tile the
360 degrees around the animal yeah so
collectively that whole set of cells
just as a collective set of place cells
is sufficient to tell the animal where
it is a collective set of head direction
cells is sufficient to tell the animal
which way it's oriented
okay
okay i think we just said all these
things are in a structure called the
well first found in a structure called
the subiculum which is part of the
hippocampus but since then they've been
found in lots of different regions you
don't need to remember that
um so they get input from lots of
different information there's many
different ways to know which way we're
oriented
for example too bad we don't have a
rotating chair
if we did i would have done the
following ridiculous thing i would have
sat one of you in it and told you to
close your eyes and i would suddenly
turn it
and the person in the chair would notice
that right that's your vestibular system
that tells you if your body's being
turned even if you yourself don't decide
to turn it it will tell you if you get
turned that's another cue that provides
input to the head direction cells just
as visual information does and
potentially auditory information and
lots of other kinds of information
so many different sources of information
feed in to inform these head direction
cells about the orientation of the
animal
okay
all right so you can think of this as
the brain's compass right
telling the organism what way they're
facing
okay and
lots of organisms have versions of this
in the fly there's an amazing structure
that was discovered just a couple years
ago where the there's a whole kind of
layout of this little neural structure i
forget what it's called but actually
spatially in that structure there's a
little array
of direction cells so actually you could
see it in a little spatial map
of direction
in that little structure in the fly
okay in humans and primates and rodents
it's not organized spatially like a
literal
map of direction
okay so now we have where you are and
which way you're facing
okay
you know one pool of cells place cells
for where you are another pool of cells
for which way you're heading
but those are just we're just getting
going here the coolest navigation
related cells
are grid cells in entering cortex okay
so this is a slice of the brain like
this
showing the hippocampus this folded up
thing right here
an interrental cortex is just
just
right next door
okay
so in internal cortex
these things were discovered a little
around a dozen years ago
maybe 15 years ago and i'm going to show
you a video of a rodent moving around
his environment
mapping out activity like we saw before
but now we're in entering cortex and
this neuron is going to be a grid cell
and you'll see why as it moves around in
its space
maybe
come on here we go
okay so there's the rodent he's moving
around that's the tether taking the
neural activity the white dots are every
time this one neuron fires we're
following one neuron this whole time
and the rodent is moving around sped up
video so you can see this happening and
at first it looks like completely random
but as the rodent keeps migrating around
in his space there you start to see that
they're like blobs in there it's not
totally random they're particular blobs
that are clustered
and oh my god those blobs are organized
in a hexagonal grid
it's a hexagon
isn't that awesome that's a grid cell
and
oops there we go we don't need to see it
again
so this is a picture of what you just
saw the trajectory of the animal and the
hot spots uh in that array and here's a
kind of smooth mathy version of where
the firing is significant in that space
both showing you hexagonal grid cells
okay
so
this is at first glance a very weird
thing why would it help to have a um
a kind of plate essentially a place
field that has multiple different places
that make it fire okay and actually
somebody asked before where their place
cells have two hot spots place cells
generally have one but grid cells as you
see have many organized in this grid
okay
um
so
the the kind of circuitry and math of
this whole system is mind-blowing and
super exciting and the talk that i
mentioned yesterday uh was on this topic
and many people are working on this and
they're working out like really deep
interesting math about how you can take
these cells how they remain arranged
spatially in the brain at multiple
scales and how you can use them to
do path integration and keep track of
how far you an animal has gone along
this trajectory it's a little bit much
for this course but i'll just say the
current thinking is
what these
what these cells enable us to do is to
keep track of how far we've gone in each
direction and that's really crucial in
navigation we need to know uh where we
are not just by the landmarks we see we
need to know how far we've gone in a
given direction and the thought is that
that's the function that these grid
cells primarily serve in navigation
um and so that's
especially important for dead reckoning
like integrating you know where you've
gone according to your trajectories okay
so you also need head direction cells at
each point so you can think of the head
direction cells is telling you the
orientation of your vector and the grid
cells of telling you the magnitude of
the vector of how far you went and you
take a whole bunch of those and you
integrate them and you know where you've
gone from your starting point
and lots of animals do all that math in
their head like it's pretty complicated
integrals right but they all do
that um okay so this is super awesome
work and uh fittingly the 2014 nobel
prize was awarded to
um
the the mosers a husband then husband
wife team
who discovered the grid cells uh and for
and also to john o'keefe who discovered
place cells uh decades earlier
um and it's um it's a super exciting
line of work and continuing continuing
to be very exciting one okay so so far
we've talked about place cells in the
hippocampus direction cells in the
subiculum and lots of other places
and end to rhino grid cells in enter
rhino cortex and this is just a
schematic diagram of where those
locations are the anatomy is complicated
and you don't need to know it no they're
all sort of in the hippocampus and it's
neighboring structures that's good
enough for for here
well okay know that the grid cells are
in internal cortex and the place cells
are in hippocampus that's worth knowing
okay
direction cells are kind of all over
um
okay
so
that's cool but there's one more cool
kind of cell actually there's several
more the new one a new one i never heard
of was reported in this job talk
yesterday but we won't go there we'll
try to keep it simple uh another well
established one is called a border cell
okay so this is the these are the place
fields of three different neurons
from an animal
moving around in this space
okay so you see how these are very
interesting kind of place fields they're
not just like a nice round blob they
stretch around a whole border of the
animal's environment
okay
so does that make you think of anything
does that ring any bells with other
stuff we've talked about in here
right think we've talked a bunch about
how the parahippocampal place area cares
about the shape of space around you
right well you might think that you'd
really want to have awareness of where
you are with respect to navigational
barriers
it turns out border cells respond not
just to walls if you put a rodent in an
environment where there's a cliff they
can't go off the border cells also
respond to the edge of that cliff okay
so any navigational barrier basically
telling you where you are with respect
to navigational barriers
okay
okay
all right
and blah blah blah okay
so
as i mentioned in the last lecture when
we talked about the para hippocampal
place area the shape of space around you
has this kind of privileged role in many
aspects of navigation
okay
so
now we're going to talk about this
problem of reorienting or regaining your
um your sense of direction once you've
been disoriented
okay
and so
um
again i mentioned this before but just
to give you in the give you the
intuition of what we're talking about
here
you come up from the subway in manhattan
or any other environment that you that's
rectilinear that you know
and you know which stop you're coming at
up at so you kind of know where you are
but you come out and you don't know
which way to head right you don't know
which way is which
all right
so that's a modern version of a classic
problem that animals face in their
environment they may know where they are
but that doesn't tell them which way
they're facing
so just to be really concrete about this
so here's an aerial view of a person
you're standing here
you have a cognitive map in your mind
and your place cells are telling you
your location in that map okay so you
know where you are in that map
but to you and you're looking down a
street so you know that you're oriented
with respect to some external
axis like this
but you don't know
how your mental map should be aligned
with that street
are you facing
like this facing north
in manhattan
or
are you facing south
right
so that's the problem of reorientation
is figuring out your particular
orientation not just your location but
which way you're facing in a known
environment okay and we've all faced
some version of this presumably at some
point
and it's annoying it takes a while to
figure out and then i don't know if
anybody's had this experience i've had
it only in manhattan because that's
where this arises for me but i'm sure
there are other locations where you come
up and you think you're going one way
and then all of a sudden like your whole
like it's like your whole mental map
goes kaboom
so how many people have had that
experience like it's very sudden and
punk date yeah
turns out that when that happens all of
your neurons flip together in unison
like they're all in cahoots they have
one version of this when you have that
experience it's because they're all
flipping together and i'll show you some
data on that in a second
okay all right
so there's a very evolutionary old
system for solving just this problem and
it's a wonderful little kind of piece of
the literature that i'm going to spend a
couple minutes on because it's so
classic
and so cool
and this started with work by randy
gallistail in the 1980s and so what he
did was he studied this problem of
reorientation that is figuring out your
orientation in a known environment once
you've been disoriented okay it's a very
particular aspect of the problem of
navigation
so he put rats in a rectangular
environment and he had them explore the
environment
and then he hid some
rat relevant thing like a little piece
of food say a chocolate chip in that
corner okay rat sees that happen rad is
interested take rat out of box before
they get to go take the the chocolate
chip
and then you disorient the rat you don't
grab them by the tail and swing them
around but you do some slower version
you don't want to make them sick you do
some slower version of that so they've
lost track of which way they're facing
okay
now you put them in a new box new box
because you don't want the smell to
still be there new box
and you see which way the rat goes
and you find that the rat goes 50 50 to
those two corners
what does that mean the rat has encoded
he doesn't go randomly to any corner
he goes to corners you know it was in a
corner he doesn't go randomly to any
corner yeah
i'm jack i'm sorry
like it's specifically in
like one of these directions
you've got to say a little more than
that what's to the left what's different
about those two corners and the other
two yeah isabel well he's looking at the
shape of the room
there's two longer walls and two
shoulder walls he recognizes that he's
basically involved he has to go to what
looks like the right complaint
exactly he has to have encoded the axis
um
the the orient the fact that the the
room has a is longer on one axis than
another
and he's essentially encoded that
chocolate chip was on the right side of
the long wall or the left side of the
short wall and both of those corners are
consistent with that that's why he goes
50 50 to them
he can't go 100 of the time to the right
corner because he has no information
that would tell him that in this
experiment okay everybody clear so it
tells you he learned where the thing is
with respect to the shape of the room
and its particular aspect ratio okay
so now the plot thickens
and now they repeat the experiment but
this time they make some very rat
salient asymmetry over here you make a
color and a texture
and you make other things to make this
wall very saliently different
okay
so you would think the rat motivated to
find the chocolate chip would now go 100
to that corner when we put them in the
new box with the same landmark queue
over there
but no the rat goes 50 50 to the same
two corners
and in control experiments many
controlled conditions you can show and
i'll show you one in a moment the rat
absolutely knows about this wall he's
encoded the presence of that asymmetric
wall so he has the information that
should enable him to break the symmetry
but he doesn't use it
that's weird you should be surprised
okay
everybody get why that's weird he could
have solved this one perfectly this time
he has the information he's not using
that information
okay
so
that's weird
but then liz spelke and her colleagues
came along 10 years later and said let's
try this with infants
and so they did the infant version where
you put the infant in a room with a
symmetrical with a um
in a rectangular room and you hide the
doors so the infant doesn't have any uh
cues other than the shape of the room
um um 18 to 24 month old infants
um and then uh you hide a toy in a
corner and you see what the infant does
and uh oh actually what you do with the
infant is you make this wall really
salient in all kinds of ways you in one
case that was red velvet and they first
showed the and these aren't like these
are i guess toddlers right they first
show them that when you knock on the red
wall music happens
totally cool riveting for a little kid
they totally get it they know all about
the music wall very salient to them
nonetheless you put them in this
experiment and they behave just like
rodents they go 50 50 to the two corners
even though they notice the red music
wall and it could have solved the
problem for them perfectly and they were
motivated they didn't use the
information
everybody get why that's
kind of interesting and kind of
surprising
okay
now you might say okay rodents infants
they're dummies
uh we wouldn't do that
us smart adult humans would we
but oh yes you would
under certain circumstances
if we tied up your language system
and there's lots of ways of doing that
one way is called shadowing so it's kind
of like simultaneous translation but you
don't translate try this sometime i do
this occasionally when i'm bored in my
car just because it's amusingly
difficult turn on the radio listen to
somebody talking and just repeat
everything they say
after they say it right
i'm not even translating it's still
demanding right so you have to you have
to be listening and producing
right okay a little running thing okay
so that's called verbal shadowing and
it's an established way to really like
tie up your language system and kind of
take it offline so you can't really use
it
when you do this experiment on human
adults
if they're verbally shadowing and their
language system is tied up they behave
just like rodents and infants that is
they use the shape of the space
but they don't use salient landmarks
that could help them solve it perfectly
they go 50 50 to the two corners
they become rats and infants
we become rats and infants
okay
so liz spelke has spun a whole
fascinating big
theoretical story
about how what this really means well
let me just say a little bit more about
about this first before i do her whole
big story okay yeah so the idea is so
first of all
why would it make sense for rodents at
least let's just consider the rats to
use only the shape of space to reorient
themselves when they're disoriented at
first glance that seems really crazy
but if you think about rodents in
natural environments
the idea is that like actually in
natural environments features change
snow comes and goes plants come and go
odors change
all those kinds of
features of the environment can change
but the
shape of the environment like that
there's a slope like this and a barrier
here and a cliff there those are more
stable features of the environment so it
actually makes evolutionary sense for
disoriented rodents at least to use the
shape of space more than the features
the colors and textures and odors of a
space
as landmarks to reorient themselves does
that make sense
and so the idea is that rodents have
through evolution kind of evolved this
system for reorienting themselves when
they lose their bearings that relies
only on the shape of space
so restrictively that even if another
cue becomes relevant and important they
don't use it
okay
the further idea is that we have some
version of this system in our heads as
well
and as smart adult humans we learn all
kinds of other strategies to get beyond
this we're not trapped with only being
able to use this one system to solve it
we can use other systems
possibly language to help us say things
to ourselves like it's on the left side
of the short wall
right that's what spelkey thinks is
there's some version in your head of
it's on the left side of the short wall
and that's why adults can do this
when their language system isn't tied up
i don't think that's exactly right but
it's a beautiful story and there's some
evidence for it okay
anyway
part of the reason i go through this
whole thing well one i think these
experiments are cool but it's also been
the basis of a kind of core idea in
cognitive science
and that idea is called informational
encapsulation
so think about just lots of syllables
for a pretty simple idea
you have this system for reorientation
and it is designed to use the shape of
space around you as the cue that you use
to reorient yourself when you're
disoriented
that system is kind of hardwired to do
just that
and if some other part of your brain has
information that could solve the problem
like the presence of a relevant feature
that could you could use
you don't have that's this your
reorientation system doesn't have access
to that information it's informationally
encapsulated it only has access to the
particular inputs that are kind of
hardwired into it okay
and so
um 20 years ago a lot of people kind of
went wild with us and said that all the
you know brain regions that i've talked
about and cognitive systems that we're
considering this course are
informationally encapsulated it's kind
of an extreme idea that goes far beyond
functional specificity to say like the
inputs are extremely restricted to each
region and that's probably not true
but there's some
limitations on the information that each
of these processors we're considering in
this course has access to and this is
kind of the kind of classic evidence
behavioral evidence that some of those
systems have very restricted inputs does
that make sense idea of informational
encapsulation not is it you know
absolute truth about the brain but as an
idea that is
interesting to consider
individually for each of the systems we
study
there's been pushback about the
extremeness of this claim that infants
and rodents only use the shape of space
there are circumstances where you can
get them to use other information but
it's definitely true that the shape of
space is the dominant cue for
reorienting
in
in rodents and infants
all right
so
when you're lost as i've mentioned
there's two questions you need to answer
where are you and which way you're
oriented right this last stuff we were
talking about is about the which way
you're oriented question
okay and i just showed you some evidence
for this general finding that the
geometric cues the shape of space
uh are the dominant cubes you use to
reorient yourself to to get your heading
back when you're disoriented okay
um but
do we really know that those cues are
different for for place recognition and
for heading direction right so i've sort
of said here are two different parts of
the problem but do they function
differently
do we really use different cues do we
use the shape of space more for heading
direction and maybe other cues for place
recognition for knowing where we are
okay so i'm going to show you a very
elegant behavioral experiment in mice
that does this all all at once in one
experiment
so this is josh julian a former lab tech
in my lab i get no credit for this
whatsoever i'm proud even though i
shouldn't be proud he was just an
endogenously smart guy who went on and
did an awesome experiment after he left
my lab and went off to grad school and
here's his awesome experiment
okay so he said let's get mice to do
both of these tasks they have to know
where they are and which way they're
oriented
okay we're gonna do the same
disorientation thing take them out turn
them around till they're disoriented but
these mice have to learn two different
environments okay one environment has
the vertical stripes on the short wall
on one of the short walls the other
environment has horizontal stripes on
the short wall
okay
so you do the same experiment you bait
one corner and you see where the rodent
goes does he go to the two opposite
corners
exactly the same experiment but he has
to remember which room is to solve the
problem he has to know whether he's he
has to discover rediscover the vertical
stripes or the horizontal stripes and
act accordingly because when he's in the
vertical context the um the thing gets
hit he does this over repeated trials
the the the food gets hid
um on the um
uh
hey let me get this right long wall on
the left
yeah right um
yeah so
when the long wall is on the left of the
rodent okay that corner the long wall is
on the left everybody oriented whereas
when he's in the in the blue context the
reward here
the long wall is on the right
okay so you have to learn those two
different environments and that the
the relevant shape cues are opposite in
each okay everybody got that
okay now
what you find is that the rodent can
learn that just fine okay so this shows
that when you put the rodent in the
vertical context in a room like this
um they go more
to these two corners than those two
corners
whereas when you put him in a um in a
horizontal context with horizontal
stripes he goes more to those two
corners than those two corners
that tells you the rodent has used the
orientation of the stripes to figure out
which room he's in and hence which two
corners are the right ones
everybody got that
but here's the amazing thing even though
in this experiment the very same animals
in the very same trials are using those
stripes
to figure out which room they're in
they don't use those stripes at all
to break the symmetry and to go only to
the great corner
which they could do
but don't
okay
so
once you've trained the rodents on these
two things that the reward is here uh in
um the ver the vertical context and
they're in the horizontal context you
disorient them you put them back in you
find that when you have vertical stripes
they go to these two corners i'm just
repeating the data when there are
horizontal stripes they go to those two
corners okay they've learned that
but why do they go to those two corners
they learn the damn stripes they use
them to know which room they're in but
they don't use them to break the
asymmetry and decide which is the
correct corner
okay so this is like a microcosm of
everything i've been saying so far all
in one experiment
right the rodents are noticing those
feature cues using them to figure out
which room they're in where are they
but failing to use those features the
orientation of the stripes
to figure out which of the two corners
is the correct one
they're not even encoding food is near
stripes
like duh that should have been easy
right so this is a beautiful i mean this
is even more evidence for informational
encapsulation of this system because it
shows us on the very same trial they
used the stripe information to know
which room they were they failed to use
it to figure out their orientation in
that room
this sort of making sense i realized
kind of subtle it's sort of simple and
subtle at the same time
um yeah so now the themselves that you
showed us on the very first
maps
what are they doing here yeah exactly
great question let's look at that that's
what we're doing next it's a great
question what are the damn place cells
doing here
great question
okay let's say a little bit more and
then we'll think about what the play
cells are doing
okay so let me just like restate cash
out the findings here
the mice are using the features to
figure out which place they're in are
they in this one or that one but they
are failing
to use those features to figure out
which is the correct corner they're
still 50 50 for the two corners even
though
logically they have that information and
they could use it and they should use it
they don't
okay
so that means the mice are using
features in this case orientation for
place recognition
but not for um regaining their
orientation within that place
i've just i'm just repeating what i said
before is that making sense
okay
so now
david's question what are the place
cells doing here great question let's
look it's mice so we can do that
or k nathat all can do that and josh
julian my amazing former lab tech so
again i get no credit whatsoever
okay so what do they do
they allow the mice to forage for crumbs
in a box like this okay
they disorient the mouse before each
trial take him out turn him around so he
doesn't know which way he's facing put
him in the box
okay
and they find that place cells have a
particular location in that box not
surprising that's what place cells do
so here are two different trials two
different cells that were mapped out in
a rodent doing this this cell responds
always in that corner
another cell responds only in that
corner okay these are just place cells
like we described before doing what
place cells do
okay
but now
sometimes those place cells are off by
180 degrees
even though the stripes should resolve
the ambiguity
okay
so those same cells
on other trials
respond to the opposite corner
so the place cells
are doing just what the rodent is doing
the place cells are confused am i facing
you know am i am i phase am i oriented
like this or am i oriented like that the
place cells don't know and the rodent
doesn't know
and the coolest thing about this
experiment is that these things are
linked on the trials where the rodent
goes to the wrong corner the place cells
are also in the wrong corner
okay they systematically determine which
way the animal will go
okay so
um oh and also as i mentioned before
like all those cells are in cahoots
they're all in sync going the same way
so when one of the cells
rotates to the opposite corner all the
other ones rotate to the opposite corner
so it's as though somehow on trial to
trial
the rodent
thinks he's oriented in one way he's
actually 50 50 which way he's oriented
he's not using the feature cues
and his behavior according to where he
looks for the food
exactly follows that way he's oriented
and so do all of his place cells
okay that's that whole system goes
together
that tells you that those place cells
are relevant behaviorally they are the
they are the system that either directly
determines or is tightly linked to the
system that determines
which way the animal thinks he's facing
okay i realize this is a little bit
complicated
um
does it make sense to you that
you know as we've been talking about
with reorientation
even though the animal should know from
this stripe
the difference between that corner and
this corner he doesn't know behaviorally
he's looking for food right there and
yet he goes 50 50. weird and stupid
right
place cells do the same thing
okay and further the place cells and the
behavior go together
yeah
so if you're reading information off of
play sales can you stop it can you
provide ah
wouldn't that be nice
turns out you can't for the reason
someone over here asked a long time ago
you i think
um
and that's because they're all
interleaved together
and if you zap just one you're not going
to one cell you're not going to have an
effect and if you zap a whole region you
get all of them and you get muck
so you can't do that manipulation
unfortunately you need some kind of
topography to do the manipulation
okay
okay so i just said how all this
i got ahead of myself how it relates to
behavior uh but just to go through that
quickly so what we've done here is
they've trained the mouse on this
classic reorientation task they
disorient the mouse before each trial
while recording from hippocampal place
cells
as before given cell flips 180 degrees
from trial to trial
despite the fact that the stripes should
disambiguate it and tell them which way
is oriented
and by the way the head direction cells
and the grid cells also flip in the same
way in cahoots with the head with the
place cells
um
but you can tell which corner the animal
will go to by looking at what the place
cells respond right
and so when the place sells
when this place cell
represents that location the animal
searches first there and when it flips
around they search in the opposite
corner
okay so all of that just shows this
really strong link between the play
cells and behavior
okay
so to recap we've talked about four
different kinds of cells involved in
representing space and navigating around
in it
place cells that are like the you are
here they respond when you're in a
particular location direction cells that
respond when you're heading in one
direction not in another direction
uh border cells that represent that that
fire when you're near a particular
border in the environment i have border
cells going right now throughout this
whole lecture i've got a batch of border
cells right that are going
grid cells that do this amazing thing of
firing when the animal is in multiple
different locations and those locations
that make it fire are arranged in a
hexagonal grid
think of it as a kind of ruler telling
the rodent how far he's gone in his
space and those grid cells are like the
rulers
yeah right
those are those are the four kind we've
talked about okay
so now
here's the cool thing all this stuff
navigation is awesome
right we need it it's important all
night you know all uh mobile animals
need it for the reasons we've been
talking about
but you you can use this whole system
for so much more than just navigation
once you have this fancy system in your
head to keep track of your location to
keep track of your direction to keep
track of where things are how you're
moving through that space you can use
that whole magnificent system in other
ways and in the last three or four years
there's just a huge number of studies
that are really starting to take this
very seriously particularly the grid
cells and thinking about how the grid
cells
i mean probably the whole system but
people have been focusing on the grid
cells
and how they're used in multiple
different situations
so here's one
okay this is a cool study where what
these guys did was they stuck a little
device hanging around people's necks the
subject's necks have little camera
aiming forward it takes pictures at
random intervals and records the
person's gps location okay
so you send them off for a few months
with this little device and you do
something to protect people's privacy i
don't know exactly how they maneuver
that but i'm sure they found a way
uh and so then they get this set of
photographs taken from this person's
kind of front view of wherever they were
over several months as they went
wherever they went in their lives okay
with a little gps tag for each
photograph okay
so then what they do is they bring the
subjects in and pop them in the scanner
and show them some of those pictures
okay
and they asked people to relive the
experience that they had when they were
looking at that thing
right if you put this on me it'd be my
monitor like all the time and i wouldn't
know which
experience to relive but i guess these
people had you know richer lives let's
hope
okay
so now what they do is they use multiple
voxel pattern analysis
in the hippocampus
while people are reliving those
experiences in the scanner by looking at
those images taken from their
front-facing cameras
okay
um and then they asked is the pattern of
response in the hippocampus like some
bunch of voxels here's some pattern
is it more similar for events the
subject remembers that are near that
were nearby in space okay
so you do this for me it's like yes i
occasionally go to the state of
cafeteria and i you know occasionally go
to the
koch center cafeteria
and i spend a lot of time at home and
those two things are closer to each
other than my home thing are the
patterns more similar for nearby
locations than for more distant
locations okay
and they were
so this is the distance on a log scale
between two patterns
that result from the subject looking at
two different images and this is the
similarity
of the pattern in the hippocampus
now some of you might be wondering in
fact i wonder this too i think this is a
cool study so i'm presenting it but it
sort of doesn't make sense to me because
everything we know about the hippocampus
is those place cells are pretty
interleaved so how you manage to get a
pattern
response
reading out a systematic location out of
the hippocampus is a mystery to me so
they can't be like fully there must be
some kind of structure in there to the
layout of those cells
um
to enable them to get this information
okay so everybody get how
it's telling you that hippocampus is is
remembering and reliving
some representation of the locations of
those
of where you had those experiences
everybody get how this shows us
but then they asked another interesting
question and they said oh
does it also represent time so we've
been talking about space for the last
two lectures but now we're like going
straight off the deep end and our first
step not even near the deep end yet is
does it do not just space but time
so they can take all those photographs
and say okay how far apart in time were
these two photographs taken
and they can do the same graph
and yes they get a relationship with
time as well the farther apart in time
people saw those two patterns the more
different the patterns in the
hippocampus
isn't that cool
okay
so that's one example showing that the
hippocampus holds some kind of
large scale of representation of not
just space but also time
and so there's a lot of work on how this
gives structures to our memories for
distances over the range of
100 meters and times between you know 15
hours
and a month i'm going to run out of time
so unless it's a clarification question
i'm going to keep going
yeah okay
yeah
yes if you just did it like that so you
have to do something to pick out
um time things that aren't confounded
with space you could you have this big
sample of pictures and you take a subset
where you balance for it absolutely they
would have to do that
i can't actually remember but they must
have done that you'd
imperfect as peer review is you'd never
get through peer review if you didn't
take care of that problem
okay okay so that's the first thing
here's another even more radical example
okay
so people have shown that grid-like
representations and i'm skipping over
most of the details here to give you the
gist because actually the details are a
bit complicated
but they've shown that people seem to
use their grid cell system
when they are thinking about conceptual
spaces
not just physical spaces
okay so there's one classic experiment
in which these guys taught subjects a
conceptual space they taught them about
different kinds of birds
okay and these birds differed on two
dimensions
they could vary in neck length or in leg
length and these things were
orthogonally varied so they made some
artificial birds that kind of filled up
that space
okay so here are some of the birds this
one has short legs and okay here's
here's one with short legs and a long
neck
and um here's one with a longer neck and
shorter leg uh wait let's see longer
legs and shorter neck right there okay
so you got every possible combination
they didn't show people a space like
that they just taught them um things
about these different birds they had to
remember their names and various facts
about them
and so the idea is that when people
learn about those birds they
mentally construct a 2d space because in
fact those birds
were generated from a 2d space varying
neck length and leg length
okay
and so then when they scan subjects
they
found essentially a neural signature of
a grid system
representing that 2d space
so even though the grid system
presumably evolved to enable us to
navigate around in a 2d space and keep
track of where we are in that 2d space
it seems like it's now getting co-opted
and being used for all kinds of
representations of 2d spaces including
extremely abstract artificial learned 2d
spaces that you weren't even taught
explicitly as a 2d space you were just
taught these birds okay
so that's pretty amazing
in another recent study they had
subjects
play a do a role playing game
while in the scanner in the role-playing
game they're interacting with virtual
characters
and those virtual characters had um
different kinds of social power and
different affiliations with other
individuals
so here's another
um kind of so the social space that was
kind of invented by the experiment
experimenters and the subjects are
playing this game interacting with other
virtual individuals who vary in social
dominance and uh and their affiliation
to to others
and they find
um place cell activity that seems to
echo
uh the position of another person
in that social space and that's
extremely abstract and yet again
parts of the navigation spatial system
are being co-opted to do this i'm not
giving you the details on how all this
is done i'm just telling you that this
studies have shown that these systems
are being co-opted for other uses
here's another very charming
non-spatial use well sort of spatial use
of place cells so those bats turns out
are extremely social organisms they have
very sophisticated social structures and
they care a lot about each other and
who's related to whom and who's doing
what to whom
and it turns out that um there are
social place cells in bats that is cells
in this bats brain if i were a vat that
would be representing your location jack
okay so not the usual thing where my
place cells are just saying where am i
i'm watching you and my place starts out
telling me where are you
right something social organisms care a
lot about including bats so they have
an observer bat here hanging upside down
and he's watching this bat fly over to
there and back and then in this
experiment he subsequently flies that
same path that's how we know that he's
watching that path because he has to
mimic the bat's path that he just
observed but while he's watching that
bat
fly on that path
what you see is here's a cell right here
here is um the path flown uh by the bat
like out and back
um and this is when the bat is flying
out and back himself and this is when
the other bat is flying out and back
blurred a little bit here's here's the
place field for self and the place field
for other they're not the same a given
cell doesn't represent the same location
when it's me who's there and when it's
the person or bad i'm watching who's
there right
but there are place fields in both cases
right
social place cells
okay
i'm going to keep going because
otherwise i'm going to run out of time
but i'll hang around after
okay
so
place this this whole system is used uh
not just for representing
social status
you know what kind of bird this is in
this abstract bird space
uh but actually for making decisions for
thinking okay so
as rats run in mazes
you can you can record we've shown this
already you can show multiple
hippocampal place cells and can you guys
imagine that if we were recording from
several different hippocampal cells at
the same time
we could read out those cells and make a
guess about where the rat is in its
location right it's just like mvpa but
done across neurons right so we have
pretty good sense of where the where the
rat is okay
so
now we have a rat navigating around in
this maze and what i'm going to show you
the white circle is where the rat
actually is
and the little color thing is telling
you where the simultaneous readout from
several place cells in that rat's
hippocampus
um would would predict where the rat is
like can we tell where the rat is by
looking at us place cells okay so right
here they're in the same place it makes
sense the rat is right there and we're
reading it out
okay so far so good
but now what we're going to do
is watch what that place cell location
does as the rat moves around in his
environment and makes decisions about
where to go next
okay
okay so what we're going to see is the
rat is going to come up to an
intersection of the maze i think it's
that in that i think it's right here
and he's going to decide am i going to
go this way am i going to go that way
and as the rat stays there deciding
which way to go and the white dot stays
there as he sits there thinking huh
should i do this should i do that you
could call it neural deliberation we
will see what his place cell activity
shows you
okay
so here we go
rat starts there whoops how do i play
this here
okay so rad is heading up there and so
are his place cells he comes up to the
intersection
he stays in one place but look what his
place cells are doing should i go over
there
i'm just interpreting what this means
but it sure looks like neural
deliberation to me
and that's what he decided everybody get
what we just saw
he while he's standing there he's in one
place but he's clearly deciding where to
go next and while he's deciding those
place cells are
essentially apparently running
simulations of where he might go next
okay so we started with this big long
list of things you need to know to
navigate around in the world and the
neural basis of all this is really not
understood yet but i've shown you what i
think are a bunch of
tantalizing snippets
um which lead to the idea that our best
current guess about the kind of neural
locus of these things which is very far
from the actual understanding of how
they work
is that the perception of the layout of
space around us the ppa and the
occipital place area are very involved
in that
also
in saying for an unfamiliar place what
kind of place is this i didn't show you
those data but you can in fact decode
whether you're looking at a scene or a
beach by looking at the pattern of
response in the ppa
we talked about the idea that the
retrosplenial cortex may be involved in
recognizing familiar locations that's a
bit of a question mark
that the idea that your map of the world
is represented in your hippocampus by
way of place cells which also say where
you are in that world
that you're heading direction in humans
i didn't give you all the evidence for
this but in humans there's quite a bit
of evidence that retrosplenial cortex is
very involved in heading direction i
guess i did give you evidence patients
who have had damage there and can
recognize places but not know how
they're oriented there
that planning routes around boundaries
in your environment uh involves the
occipital place area and the peripheral
campbell place area
and that this business of reorientation
seems to particularly involve
heading direction cells in humans most
likely in retrospective cortex
so you don't need to memorize all that i
mean you know i don't care that much
about the locations what i want you guys
to understand is what are these problems
that are involved in navigation and what
kinds of things can we learn with
different kinds of behavioral and neural
measures and you may have noticed in the
last couple lectures that i presented
lots of behavioral data because actually
so far the richest insights about how
the system actually works still come or
many of the rich ones come from
behavioral data okay quiz is in two
minutes does anybody want to ask me a
question before the quiz
yeah so you have to do lots of controls
to to work that out and i didn't show
you any of the you know details of the
data uh but yeah these guys are pretty
careful and there are all these things
there are many different ways in which
people are watching
neuro
watching hippocampal neurons and
decoding trajectories from hippocampal
neurons
you may have heard about replay which is
like a big thing in this department
tanagawa and wilson labs study this
where you have a rodent moving around in
one trajectory
during the day and then you record from
those neurons at night and you see
replay of the trajectories that the
rodent went through in the previous day
and so there you have to be really
careful to say okay there's a lot of
data and a lot of noise and is this
really more than the noise and it is but
it takes a lot of statistical work to
show that
yeah
scenario um say like a place that i know
yeah uh with the nuance
um the same neurons inspire if i go back
to that environment i've assumed for
like the truth yeah yeah
but
but then you can't really have that or
like you can't be
it's a good question how do we have
enough neurons yeah especially for some
place we go every six months are they
sitting around waiting for us to go back
there no there's some recycling of
neurons across very different locations
so within that location they'll be
consistent but yes you do recycle so the
same neuron will have one place cell in
this environment and it may or may not
have a place cell in another environment
that's a good question
you